what are they going to do to him next is
he going to be going away anytime soon
is he still going to stay loud are they
going to try to silence him because you
know when when even after the election
if they follow if you if if this is the
same Playbook being played okay on the
left and the right and your symbol
scenario is Trump of Brazil you know
what comes next is they gotta
de-platform him from everywhere which is
Twitter which is Facebook which is
YouTube which is all of that right
is is that how they're gonna silence him
and is he gonna stay in Brazil is he
gonna leave is he going to get her what
are they gonna do to him knowing the
history of Brazil what do you think is
going to happen next to him so you
Rodrigo mentioned that yesterday
bolsonaro's party officially challenged
election I read that yeah correct okay
the claims are hard to deny
okay claims are very hard to deny
um the the the the whole system is is
plotted
okay and I I was part of the people that
say that said after the the first uh
round of the elections I said no no I
don't see any evidence of you know what
are the chances of things flipping when
Supreme Court owns 9 out of 11 in
Alexander let me yes that's important
yeah so he he challenged not spoiler
alert Supreme Court's not going to say
anything but the law in Brazil says the
attorney general has has to
ask for new election okay
and the court might deny it again
or you're talking about a guy in the
Constitution 1988 communist Constitution
that says if you get impeached you can't
run again for eight years but then the
judge says hey let's rip it apart and
it's okay not this time and she can run
again so if they have a reputation of
doing that and they own 9 out of 11. I
mean there's there's an expectation
Trump had six three Supreme Court and
nothing happened you know so that that
you know what which is the the biggest
difference from Brazil and United States
I think is the military yes he's correct
because the institutions are against
people that was going to be my question
they're gonna ignore uh so they're
exhausting all the institutional what is
their their position today and by the
way will you consider the institution
still a center institution independent
enough the the military the military
military they're legalists they follow
the law they they're a strict and they
are patriotic patriotic and they want
they kind of don't accept uh what
happened in Brazil and and Lula being
the commander-in-chief uh like they they
are we have some generals uh Tweeting or
uh two two a week ago the The Joint
Chiefs issued a joint statement which is
I've never seen it happening and it's
Strong saying that they're listening to
the streets and that they're
hoping that our institutions listen to
the streets and fix what's going on
and but they they use a very weird
language on the text saying we have the
role of the Protectors of democracy and
institutions and throughout history we
exerted the role as moderators of
countries conflicts and and then they
put pressure on the Congress like you
need to do something because we are
watching what's going on so nobody knows
what's what's going to happen like the
people in on the streets right now they
believe they still believe Lula won't be
able to to be the next president they
still believe that there's a large chunk
of that I have a very I mean listen it's
it's well we're not optimistic as well
yeah I I have the only reason the only
reason I have a very hard time uh
Alexander this guy first of all is 54
years old that's not good news for you
he's not 78 he's 54. he was born in 68
that's a young man right there yeah he
ain't going away for a long time and he
seems like he works out and he's pretty
energized and he drinks coffee so this
guy's going to be fired up for a long
time this is not not good news you asked
some somebody
that's that's what's going on in jail
like he should be arrested we have a a a
a judge that just retired yeah he just
retired and he gave a very strong very
powerful speech to the guys to the
people on the streets the pills
Scorchers yeah he's retired yeah and his
he just retired but that's retired no no
I know but that's not we understand the
the law he's acknowledgment yeah and he
was like very quietly saying that
Alessandra de mores needs to be arrested
who has the power to do that the
president could anyone could ask this
the next time the next time uh uh and by
the way I'm not trying to take hope away
or anything like that I'm just saying 9
out of 11 and the last time uh uh when
he won uh let's not forget Obama called
Lula one of the best politicians in the
world and he was on Time Magazine 2010
one of the top 100 most inflation men in
the world that's Lula we're talking
about yeah he knows how to Market
himself he's only he knows how to sell
himself and he knows how to play the
game he's been around for a very very
long time playing this game he's a pro
amongst Pros to pin who against who he
knows how to talk to the Evangelical and
kind of persuade this I'll strategize
he's he is he is the credit goes to him
as a strategist I don't agree with his
policies I don't agree he has the world
community and then the other part with
China he's not as smart as you think you
just have he just has a lot of energy is
not necessarily smart to me strategy is
wise to me smart is intellectual
educated degrees you you do not want to
go against a wise competitor let me tell
you you would much rather go against a
smart competitor than a wise company so
with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetaining it says future looks bright
here future looks bright here we got him
in white we got them in Black we got
them in red or black on black sold out
these are about to to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]